اسبوع باريس للموضه حدث عالمي بيلفت انظار
العالم كله كل سنه خصوصا المهتمين بهذا
العالم وامس كان في
افتتاحه وكامس كان امس افتتاح الاسبوع
وبدا العرض لدار سكاربيل والعرض قالب
الدنيا والسبب هو الفساتين اللي ظهروا
فيها عارضات ازياء واللي كانت مزينه برؤوس
حيوانات مفترسه
وكانها حقيقيين فشوفنا يومين كامبل
تصميمات عليها رؤوس فهد واسد والذئب
كمان كانت من الحضور ولفته الانظار
بالفستان مزين براس اسد
[موسيقى]
التصاميم هذه سرعان ما قسمت العالم بين
ناس اعجبها والناس لا لكنها كمان كانت سبب
انقسام من نوع مختلف وخاصه في عالم
المدافعين عن حقوق الحيوان فمنظمه بدء
الشهيره المدافع عن حقوق الحيوان نددت
باستخدام دار الازياء لرؤوس حيوانات بحجم
طبيعي في تصاميمها ولو انها رؤوس مزيفه
وقالت انه هذه التصاميم بتمجد الصيد
للترفيه كمان استنكرت استخدام الحرير
والصوف في التصاميم وقالت انه في ديدان
قذف بتقتل حيه من اجلها وخرفان بيتم
استغلال الحمل دار الازياء كانت سبقت هذه
الهجوم واعلنت في بيان انه ما في اي حيوان
تعرض للاذى خلال تصميم المجموعه وان
الرؤوس صناعيه لكن هذا ايضا ردت عليه فتاه
واعتبرته تصريح كاذب
كمان عبر انستغرام على الانتقادات
المواجهه ضدها وعبر بالفستان واكد انه راس
الاسد اللي زي الفستانها من صنع الانسان
من مواد صناعيه ومحقيقي ابدا لكن مو كثير
اعذروها خاصه انه الاحد تاريخ مع منظمات
حقوق الحيوان ومن سنتين كانت عرضه لهجوم
من قبلهم من بعد ما لقتوها طالعه من متجر
همم يعني بيبيع فروه حقيقي من الحيوانات
فيعني لو حطينا الحيوانات وجد الحبوب على
جنب في اطلاله ثانيه يعني مشاهدينا بتفوز
عادي كده بالمرتاح يعني بلقب الاغرب في
عرض امس وهي اطلاله مغنيه الراب الامريكيه
دوجات واللي ما كان حتى
لاصابع رجليها ومغطيتها الافقطع الكريستال
[موسيقى]